o olá boa tarde
hoje eu vim contar para vocês uma
história
e de como nascem as famílias ea história
também de mulheres e não é à toa que a
minha história também né tô aqui eu vim
de uma família de cinco mulheres né não
cinco mulheres fortes até muito pouco
tempo eu morava com elas era minha avó
minha mãe e somos três irmãs
eu quando era pequena eu perguntava para
minha mãe é como é que eu nasci
oi e ela sempre repetir uma história que
ficou muito marcada para mim eram
história muito forte que ela dizia para
mim assim ah quando você nasceu eu quase
morri no seu quarto
e eu naquela época não tinha aparelho de
ultrassom não tinha esses aparelhos que
dão para a gente a segurança de que a
gente tá bem de que o bebê está bem e aí
nas vésperas de você nascer o médico
precisou viajar e eu fiquei abandonada
tive que ir para o plantão e sofri muito
sofri horas até que o médico resolveu
fazer a minha cesárea porque eu não
tinha passagem minha bacia estreita você
nasceu roxinha com unhas grandes
o e naquele momento eu imaginava aquela
cena e ela devia também você foi parar
no balão eu fui parar no balão de
oxigénio e eu imaginava aquela cena o
que que era um balão de oxigênio ea
minha imagem de unhas grandes e roxinha
só depois de muito tempo que eu vim
saber que bebês nascem roxo porque tem
pouca oxigênio eles não precisam né e aí
eu perguntava para ela e onde é que tava
meu pai
oi e ela dizia assim a comemorando em
algum boteco seu nascimento e eu acho
que de tanto ouvir aquela história eu
decidi que eu queria uma história
diferente eu disse eu decidi que eu
queria fazer uma história que fosse
oposta àquela mas ele ela foi meu ponto
de partida
o viés que o meu tempo chega eu
procurava alguém que fosse muito bacana
que pudesse me acompanhar que fosse
parceiro que fosse sensível encontrei
aqui comigo a gente conversou muito como
todo mundo decide engravidar abrir mão
do método contraceptivo e só tem certeza
que tá grávida depois que faz um exame e
aí a gente precisa do exame para
comemorar e assim a gente fez né
comemoramos com a família depois com os
amigos e fizemos tudo durante esse tempo
para ter certeza que tudo a correr bem
né e alimentei bem essa atividade física
procurei os melhores profissionais que
pudessem me dar a segurança
ah e assim foi ia no pré-natal fazer
algumas perguntas mas é sempre tudo
muito rápido né tudo muito protocolar e
ele era muito cuidadoso querido né mas
sempre muito rápido a sensação que eu
tinha que faltava uma coisa que eu não
sabia dizer bem o que que era e aí com o
tempo uma amiga que tinha feito um curso
comigo de formação em terapia familiar
me convidou para participar de uma roda
ela tava chegando em conquista e ela
tava muito entusiasmada porque ela tinha
tido uma cesariana
bom e depois da cesariana ela ai depois
essa cesariana ela percebeu que ela
queria viver uma experiência de um parto
natural e ela conseguiu o parto natural
veio para conquista e chegando em
conquista ela falou eu quero que outras
mulheres têm acesso a isso também e
assim foi a gente tinha nós éramos três
gestantes uma puérpera que ela um
obstetra e duas enfermeiras
oi e o primeiro encontro foi
simplesmente sensacional
e foi experiência linda em que ninguém
ali era sabido ninguém tinha
conhecimento a mais que ninguém mesmo as
profissionais que estavam ali elas
estavam no modelo de acolhimento e
acontece entre a gente algo que a gente
chama de ressonância que a capacidade de
que a minha história seja tocada pela
história do outro e a gente se tocava
nas nossas histórias era engraçado
porque os medos as dúvidas as perguntas
eram todas muito parecidas e eu entendi
que o que faltava para mim faltava
também para elas
bom e ali eu saio daquele espaço com a
sensação é de que eu queria mais e aí
marcaram novo encontro nós somos um novo
encontro minha barriga foi crescendo
convidei meu companheiro ele foi em
alguns rodas comigo mas naquele momento
a roda ela tinha muita mulher
é mas ele ele ele muito participativo
vamos lá vão participar da roda e fomos
e aí fui vivendo e no momento em uma das
rodas eu me lembrei de uma cena que foi
uma cena que me marcou muito em um dos
cursos que eu fiz durante a minha
formação um curso de teoria do apego uma
mulher entrou no curso com tecido
amarrado nela com bebê dentro do tecido
era um slim slim é um tecido de
amarração que mulheres africanas
utilizam e ela foi dentro desse curso
referência e exemplo tempo inteiro
professor tem que ter mostrado a ela no
primeiro momento fiquei meio angustiada
que eu pensei meu deus esse bebê vai
morrer asfixiada dentro do seio dessa
mulher e aí ela sentou do meu lado eu
ficava toda hora olhando para ver se seu
bebê estava vivo e foi muito engraçado
só nos três dias de curso é como eles se
comunicavam muito bem naquele processo
ela tava muito tranquila porque é
eu falei com ela ela podia carregar para
onde fosse e o bebê tava muito tranquilo
porque ele também tava com ela e quando
ele se angustiava ela virava um
pouquinho corpo voltava o seio na boca e
ele mamava e ali mesmo ele arrotava e
dormia e acordava e todo o processo era
feito nesse maranha mento do corpo com
corpo foi uma história muito bonita e
quando eu me lembrei contém na roda eu
tive a curiosidade de voltar e pétala
onde é que tá essa mulher deixa eu ver
aí fui no facebook facebook de amigos
conhecidos e consegui achar ela e aí é
tocada pelas histórias das rodas que me
fazia muito sentido eu fui tocada também
pelas imagens do parque dessa mulher
imagens muito fortes imagens de família
ela teve um parto domiciliar um par tem
que a filhinha mais velha dela
participou que a mãe dela participou que
o cachorrinho dela participou
é uma imagem de uma festa que
transbordava naquele ambiente familiar e
naquela hora eu pensei eu quero ver isso
eu não quero viver outra coisa que não
seja isso
o e esqui continuei minha jornada
uma semana após semana mês após mês
pré-natal né consultas e quando eu fiz
34 semanas eu voltei para o meu obstetra
e se ele assim eu quero ter um parto
natural eu sei que eu não vou conseguir
ter um parto domiciliar aqui em vitória
da conquista mas eu quero ter um parto
natural e ele me disse assim olha para
mim e eu li
e ele falou confia em mim
bom e aquela frase ele saiu da mesa a
gente se abraçou e aquela frase foi
extremamente angustiante para mim porque
não era o que eu queria ouvir eu queria
ouvir que ele dissesse para mim assim
confio em você confio no seu corpo
confie nas suas extra lidade confia em
todas as outras mulheres que passaram
por aqui e que também conseguiram parei
e ele me pediu que eu confiar nele
e foi muito forte pra mim e eu saí de lá
me lembro de ter abraçado thai editar
ele eu não estou segura se eu tiver lá
no momento de vulnerabilidade e ele
pediu para confiar nele eu não tenho
outra coisa eu vou ter que confiar e ele
disse para mim então vamo dar se você
não tá segura não é parceiro e a gente
bancou né nessa cultura que exige o
único médio até o final para que você
confia nele a gente bancou junto vamo
mudar e eu dei uma desculpa qualquer
para ele
ei ei disse que não dava que eu ia
tentar né uma outra coisa e foi para um
plano b vão excelente plano b é esse o
dia chega 39 semanas e 6 dias todas as
histórias que eu ouvi durante a roda
porque nós temos um compromisso com a
gente nós voltávamos para contar como
havia acontecido com cada um de nós era
um compromisso de compartilhar aquela
história
eu e elas não estavam e a gente ouvia e
perguntava e tirar a dúvida e era
maravilhoso meu dia chegou então cortada
por aquelas histórias todas eu sabia que
tinha uma coisa que era diferente e que
eu já tinha ouvido naquelas mulheres que
juntos a gente viveu nosso trabalho de
parto
bom então trabalho de parto que a gente
começou em casa em um determinado
momento foi para o hospital eu tive
minha doula uma mulher que estava comigo
e que tinha ancestralidade nela para
você mulher entendia de fato o que que
eu precisava e a gente viveu essa
história juntos eu eu companheiro e
medula eu não quis a minha mãe eu tinha
muito medo dos medos dela porque durante
esse processo ela dizia para mim assim
mas minha filha será que você não tenha
das estreita como eu e eu tinha estudado
tudo sobre bacias estreitas entende que
bacia estreita se chama desproporção
céfalo-pélvica e que só pode ser
diagnosticado no processo em trabalho e
se eu tava ali eu precisava viver essa
experiência para saber se de fato se
aconteceu não
eu fui para o meu trabalho de parto vive
e a gente tem um momento que a gente
chama de hora da covardia por volta de
78 cm de dilatação a gente começa a ter
medo né e adivinha quem apareceu na
minha cabeça ela minha mãe os medos dela
ela não tava lá mas os medos estavam em
mim as histórias dos decos
hoje eu fui para o trabalho espaço e
tudo também é bem até aqui no finalzinho
eu pedi analgesia o médico que fez minha
analgesia fez analgesia muito dura muito
comprida eles não tem costume de fazer
analgesia parto natural e eu perdi os
movimentos da perna tive que ficar
deitada e aí não expulsivo já no
finalzinho minha médica me disse uma
sala eu vou precisar fazer uma
intervenção zinha você vai precisar de
um sócio é preciso de alívio é tranquilo
a gente só vai pegar mas eu vou precisar
de ajuda e quem entrou no centro
cirúrgico meu médico aquele que ficou
comigo 34 semanas
o que ele entrou no movimento firme
precisava resolver e ele fez um corte na
minha vagina se chama é episiotomia já
se sabe que a fisionomia de rotina é
chamada de violência obstétrica e eles
não entendem muito isso eles também
estão prisão sistema eles aprendem assim
e para ele é comum fazer cortes na
vagina mas no meu corpo não era comum né
eu não tava acostumada eu não queria
aquilo mas eu não entendi muito bem a
cena é muita adrenalina e muita emoção e
eu não entendi muito bem que tinha
acontecido
é mas a menina seu bem veio para o meu
colo é respirou o amor na primeira hora
a gente ficou junto né foi bem bacana
assim esse primeiro momento apesar de
estranho até entender o que tinha
acontecido
e de lá para cá a roda mudou muito né
hoje nós não somos uma única roda nós
somos algumas rodas em vitória da
conquista todas elas protagonizados por
mulheres que viveram histórias parecidas
com as minhas né mas a gente tem um
objetivo comum que é empoderamento
feminino e o fortalecimento da ideia de
família as rodas hoje elas são
preenchidas de homens os homens eles
chegam lá meio assustados mas logo acha
o seu lugar e entendem que precisa tomar
para si também o protagonismo de ser pai
e acha um lugar muito especial
e depois que eu subi para o quarto
camille nós ficamos ali juntas ela no
meu colo e eu me lembro de ter ficado
assim umas duas horas chorando chorando
eu olhava para ela eu chorava muito
o e pensava com uma natureza forte né
como a natureza ela é nos conectar e eu
olhava para aquela cena né de não ali
perfeita contando dedinhos mas eu olhava
para ela como uma pessoa uma pessoa que
tava ali e que o meu corpo tinha
produzido uma pessoa
ah e não era só uma pessoa era mais uma
mulher amelinha uma mulher uma nova
geração de mulheres da minha família que
me da raiz que me que me conecta com a
minha sacralidade e eu era mais uma
representante agora adulta esse feminino
amelie vai fazer 6 anos em abril a roda
fez seis anos em outubro
e a roda hoje é como eu disse é
diferente e o que eu prometi chama ele
quando ela nasceu é de que eu tentar ia
todos os dias da minha vida fazer com
que ela não precisa se sentir medo que
foi o que eu senti que foi o que minha
mãe sentiu e o que é que a maioria das
mulheres sentem quando estão nascendo de
parto e por isso a roda existe até hoje
porque a minha resistência é o lugar que
ocupo ea lugar que todos os dias eu
encontro novas histórias e novas
mulheres para dizer que é possível e que
a gente pode sim tem um partes positivo
como é que eu tô
e a gente pode sim ter experiências
bonitas experiências positivas
experiências que fortaleçam a família
obrigada gente
e aí